Donald Trump's FCC makes the internet
free again we will explain so-called net
neutrality since apparently nobody has
any idea what it is
then Cabot Phillips and Paul Bois during
the panel of deplorable z' to discuss
deregulation sex and the deregulation of
sex
finally the mailbag I'm Michael Knowles
and this is the Michael Knowles show
[Music]
Trump just deregulated the Internet this
vote just came out good stuff very very
cough FA now I realize nobody knows
anything about net neutrality and wags
actually that isn't true it's that
nobody who supports net neutrality knows
anything about it so very quickly here's
what you need to know today there was an
FCC vote to repeal Obama era regulations
on the internet that the judiciary has
consistently struck down the vote led by
FCC Chairman Ajit PI who himself
actually was appointed to the FCC by
Barack Obama means that broadband
providers will now be able to offer
people a wider variety of service
options and price points and have more
incentive to build networks especially
in rural areas on underserved areas how
awful I know it's so terrifying
net neutrality that phrase is an
Orwellian named regulation that empowers
the government to force broadband
networks to treat all data traveling
over their networks in the same way
downloading high-speed porn uploading
your child's book report internet
providers can't offer different plans
for different purposes under net
neutrality which is now struck down how
did all of this begin in 2005 the FCC
declared that broadcast internet the
internet that we all use broadband
internet rather is specifically not a
telecommunication service and therefore
it is not subject to common carrier
rules and rates and services and
regulations this made total sense the
freewheeling unregulated nature of the
Internet is why it evolved so rapidly so
efficiently to serve customer demands
ever since Al Gore invented it has
really blown up its dynamic the line in
the internet between successful
investment and failure is very thin so
it makes a lot of sense not to regulate
this thing to death things got a little
murky in 2008 so even though the FCC
explicitly acknowledged three years
earlier that broadband is not a
telecommunication service it issued
guidelines which in 2008 it bizarrely
started to enforce their just guidelines
you don't have to follow them in 2008
for some reason they change their mind
and started forcing these companies to
follow guidelines that it itself said
they don't have to now fortunately a
federal appeals court in 2010 smacked
the FCC down
they pointed out that the agency itself
had admitted that it didn't have
regulatory authority undeterred in its
quest to grab government control of the
Internet
later that year the FCC adopted formal
rules regulating the internet under the
very Orwellian terminology net
neutrality or open Internet that sort of
thing regulating the internet means open
Internet and free Internet is is bad I
don't I don't know how they arrived at
this this terminology but even then even
after they adopted these formal rules
there had to be exceptions winners and
losers selected arbitrarily by the
government some people and services hog
bandwidth on the innocent end of this is
Netflix and Hulu on the other end and I
know none of our listeners and know
anything about this but on the other end
there are people binging high-speed
internet porn so the FCC had to exempt
quote reasonable network management this
included certain mobile networks
obviously they had to do this otherwise
the it would have slowed the growth of
imp the internet and Internet companies
tremendously but all of it was pretty
unfair so the Internet service providers
sued in 2014
once again the courts struck down the
FCC's rules because the FCC lacked
authority so in 2015 this on a godless
headless regulatory agency the FCC got
tired of the game emboldened by Barack
Obama's governing principle of if it
moves tax it if it keeps moving
regulated if it stops moving subsidize
it the FCC changed its tune and they
insisted that they indeed had the right
to regulate broadband and therefore the
Internet as a public utility like the
phone company
this decision was a doubly awful it was
awful for two reasons on the one hand
the federal government should get its
grubby paws off of the internet go away
we don't want you there go I know Al
Gore invented you but that's enough
we'll keep the internet free thank you
very much on the other hand if the
federal government is insisting on
making the internet less free it should
be our elected representatives in
Congress who do it not some totally
unaccountable unelected bureaucracy at
the FCC congresswoman Marsha Blackburn
Republican explain this she said if
there are net neutrality rules it's
something to be
by Congress not the FCC they're on our
turf and we need to reclaim it
absolutely right now the pro regulation
crowd are typically hysterical they
predict that you will not be able to
access video streaming services ISPs
will have total control over customers
this is what they always say it just
doesn't happen because these companies
they're not out to get you they're not
out to oppress you they want your money
they want your business less regulation
means there's more room for competitors
to swoop in and offer you a better deal
this always happens deregulation does
not raise the price of goods it
decreases the price of goods now there
has been no case in the courts of an isp
violating net neutrality that actually
arose involved involving the dominant
internet provider abusing its market
power in reality that hasn't happened in
the fantasies of hysterical lefties that
happens all the time but not in reality
the main industry that's freaking out is
high-speed porn pornography is a hundred
billion dollar per year industry it
makes all of that money by giving you
free bandwidth hogging videos that
display ads and infect your computer
with viruses nasha Bulls Cassie Murdock
Murdock China exemplifies the lefty
hysteria she wrote quote Thursday's FCC
vote to end net neutrality will kill
many of the things you enjoy most about
the Internet in its current form but
chief among them is your ability to
access copious amounts of free adult
entertainment this is true she isn't
kidding by the way that's not satire she
writes about how awful it is that we're
gonna lose our precious our precious our
most favorite thing fast internet free
internet porn which by the way isn't
true it's been it was around before 2015
it'll be around long after
now last year pornhub viewers alone used
3110 petabytes of bandwidth petabyte
that's that's one above terabyte which
is above gigabyte that's over three
billion gigabytes on just pornhub.com
alone that's one porn website people are
paying basically nothing for it now the
porn industry is so desperate to keep
these rules these unfair regulations in
place these government subsidies of porn
or government
incentives for for cheap internet porn
for users at the cost of ISPs and other
Internet users they're threatening to
Doc's Republican politicians who oppose
the deregulation snagglepuss pour in CEO
it's the name of the company snagglepuss
porn CEO Andrew Cunard said there are
lots of Republicans who just assumed
we'd keep their dirty boy secrets we
assumed they wouldn't screw with us
I guess that unofficial deal is off so
what do you need to know the people in
favor of the euphemistically titled net
neutrality government regulation of the
Internet are Democrats pimps and
extortionists but I repeat myself the
people opposed to net neutrality
regulation are conservatives
libertarians federal judges and
economists in particular FCC's own chief
economists before during and after the
regulation Michael Katz Timothy Brennan
Michelle Connolly all of whom point out
that net neutrality regulations make no
economic sense Barack Obama's FCC
regulated the internet just two years
ago you wouldn't know that from looking
at Twitter you as you would think that
it's been around since the country was
founded net neutrality is two years old
did the internet work just fine two
years ago then there is no reason not to
repeal net neutrality there's no reason
not to what are you so worried about it
was fine two years ago it'll be fine
next year when hysterical lefties who
tell you that the internet will be
ruined forever
because two-year-old anti-constitutional
anti Liberty regulations will be
repealed just get out your leftist ears
tumblr collect them drink deep that
salty delicious ambrosia because
President Trump hasn't even finished out
his first year in office it's too good
mmm they're almost too salty today I
have to put that down I need some water
to wash that down with to discuss we
will bring on our panel Cabot Phillips
and Paul voie but listen gentlemen
before we get to this I do want to talk
about I do want to talk about net
neutrality and mostly just all of the
copious leftist tears that are pouring
out from all sides because no one
understands what that is but it's not
time for that yet you know I know that
because I'm wearing my movement watch my
sweet movement watch look how cool that
is
movement watches was founded on the
belief that style shouldn't break the
bank the watchmakers goal is to change
the way consumers think about fashion by
offering very high quality minimalist
products at revolutionary prices now I
really like watches and I really hate
paying a lot of money so if if you went
into a department store watch like this
could easily cost you three four hundred
dollars but the movement watch guys have
figured out that they can skip all of
those markups by selling direct to you
online that's why they've sold over 1
million watches to customers in over 160
countries around the world
it has solidified itself as the
fastest-growing watch company and it's
because there are no regulation so you
don't have a lot of regulations on the
watch industry so they're able to give
customers what they want very fitting
for our topic today now holiday shopping
can be tough Christmas shopping is very
tough thanks to movement all that
gift-giving anxiety can disappear with
the press of a button the price point
that these begin with these watches is
$95 that is nothing for a quality watch
it is a really really good deal so
finish your holiday shopping finish
christmas is just around the corner get
a movement watch for someone on your
list or yourself that's what I would go
on I'd say oh I'm gonna get it for you
know my brother or my yada yada yada I
just get a bunch for me because at a
price point like 95 dollars you can
afford to get a few you know put them on
wear them with different outfits it's
either really nice so move and watch
it's 95 dollars over 1 million watches
sold get 15% off today that is just for
our listeners free shipping and free
returns there's no risk at all you'll
save 15% if you go to m/v MT comm /
coffe FA Co V Fe Fe movement calm em BMT
calm / co FF a that is it is the time
right now to type that in the watch is
really clean design makes a great
fashion statement now is the time to
step up your watch game come on you're
an adult we're not we're not little kids
anymore you need to wear a watch to to
one keep track of your own time and to
let people know that you have places to
be and people to see so step up your
watch game join the movement
MVM t-dot-com / co FFA co v fe fe okay
let's bring on our guys gentlemen let's
begin with cabin cabin with all of the
right enemies is there any argument for
Obama's net neutrality regulations oh
the argument that they're trying to make
is that this is going to hurt people you
see on Twitter millions people are gonna
die from this I don't see a legitimate
argument that's being made by the left
that you know the arguments are making
sound convincing but that's because
they're not based in fact and it is
interesting to see how the left is
always talking about how they care about
the little guy they want to support
people in need if they actually cared
about you know low-income families in
America they would support what happened
today because now this means that for
that family that doesn't need the
world-class internet you know in these
low-income areas and can't afford it
they can now pay for a cheaper package
and just get what they need they don't
have to get the same internet it's gonna
make cost cheaper for them many times
it's gonna be better for all Americans
look what I'm driving to work on the
highway and I look over and I see people
in the express lane you have to pay a
$10 toll to give them that Lane and so I
understand those people are driving that
Lane right now because they pay a little
bit more because they had the resource
to do so and that's why they're getting
the best possible service right there
and I think it's a little bit similar
with what's happening with net
neutrality today and and again anyone
that supports a regulated industry they
should oppose what happened today anyone
that once actual the market to decide
what's best anyone that once businessmen
to decide what's best for their
companies and Americans decide what's
best for their families this is a win
for the free market and like you said
making the internet free again I don't
know what your coin to that but I hope
I'm gonna trademark exactly what
happened you're absolutely right
regulation always hurts the little guy
on both the consumer side and on the
industry side it hurts the little guy
who can't afford the big expensive
internet package that the government
forces you to buy he just wants the
cheaper internet package so he can I
don't know get some work done help his
business educate himself this that or
the other thing and it also hurts the
little guy in business because you have
these giants who are trying to squeeze
little people out with burdensome
government regulation they're saying
that this is gonna stop the free flow of
information on the Internet nothing
could be further from the truth first of
all we're just talking about bandwidth
we're talking about weather is
peas can prioritize certain information
over other information certain websites
over other websites in a free market in
a comp in a market where there is
competition and certainly there will be
more competition as these technologies
evolve as they always do but there are
people who are preventing the free flow
of information on the Internet
that's Google that's YouTube that's
Facebook I mean these guys are blacking
out information
they're killing conservatives the other
day they're a friend of mine who tried
to post an article on Facebook it was a
conservative article but it was
absolutely truthful Facebook wouldn't
let him do it
Facebook said do you know that this is
fake news do you know that this this
might not be real consider looking at
this fact-checking website this
left-wing fact-checking website before
you post it those are the guys who if
the government's gonna regulate anybody
it should be them it should be Google
and Facebook and YouTube but it's
certainly not the the ISPs it's a total
distraction and the the fact that people
who support this repeal today can
explain pretty easily what net
neutrality is and what it means and the
people who are screaming about people
dying can't do that they have no idea
what it is they don't know that it's
only two years old that tells you
everything you need to know about this
issue there's a lot of demagoguery on
this issue and it's all on the left paul
bois your Cardinal your eminence will
this actually hurt the porn industry
they are baring their fangs they're very
upset about this is it gonna damage this
gazillion dollar a year industry
unfortunately no Michael it's not going
to hurt the porn industry all right I
mean no that's terrible that steroids
unless we go back to the days where porn
is illegal in this country I am sorry to
say that porn is probably going to be
doing quite well in this country
something tells me that even if people
were getting charged $100 extra a month
it would still be doing well my profits
might even go up I mean the worst that
could happen is that some guy who spends
three hours a day on pornhub might and I
emphasize the word might be charged a
tiny extra a month but something tells
me even competition will root that
so no the porn industry is not going to
die unfortunately and but the thing is
who can put a price on self degradation
who can put a price on it's priceless
speaking of weird sex there this is
actually pretty sad story Dan Johnson a
Kentucky lawmaker who was accused of
drunkenly kissing and grabbing a 17 year
old girl on New Year's Eve four years
ago she was 17 four years ago he shot
himself in the head yesterday a day
earlier he denied the allegations on
social media he asked his friends to say
strong for his wife Johnson was 57 years
old with five children and nine
grandchildren two more on the way in the
tummy as he wrote lefties on Twitter
celebrated the suicide cabin how does
this end we are way past Harvey
Weinstein now what he's accused of is
not is not Harvey Weinstein's behavior
now drunken passes at young women over
the age of consent are being conflated
with rape and pedophilia does every guy
who has ever acted stupidly around women
now have to shut up or kill himself yeah
I think that's where the danger comes in
it's really tempting to just pour on
anytime you know someone comes out and
says you know this person did this to me
whether it's right or wrong I think it's
it's really easy to just say all this is
horrible we can all agree this person
deserves this they deserve this it's
really easy to get involved in that just
character assassination I think it's
important that a we gather as many facts
as we can before we're making serious
accusations like this and in a case
where you know you're not able to prove
anything
is it really you know something where
someone's life should be ruined
automatically where there's there's no
way of proving it even if it is
something that did happen it's tough I
think you know these cases as often as
possible need to be handled in criminal
courts where we you know an actual you
know we can have actual investigations
into what's going on but the the he
Stacey Shea she say that's that's it's
dangerous and it's certainly it's sad to
see when it comes to this it's not an
something anyone's I don't know I don't
know what to make in this you know it's
it it makes you wonder if this guy was
was innocent and he was just not wanting
to deal with all this or if he was
guilty he was dealing with the guilt of
all of it but I don't know where this
goes I don't
this will be the first time this happens
I think we're gonna concede continue to
see people dealing with you know these
kind of cues Asians in this way and it's
important that we get all these cases
out in the open so we can start to find
out you know who's a good person who's
not but you never want to see it in like
this and also you don't want to see you
know false accusations happening so it's
it's it's tough to really go there most
of this guy the accusation even if we
believe the accusation which I I don't
know if there is evidence for it or
against it the accusation is that four
years ago he made a pass drunkenly at a
New Year's Eve party the drunkest night
of the year he made a drunken pass at a
young woman who's who's over the age of
consent she's still teenager but there's
nothing illegal about that he made a
pass at her and that was it it
apparently ended there no Weinstein like
rape no stalking no craziness this is
not the sort of thing that one should
kill oneself over but in this present
climate I can see why that temptation
would exist but comparing this guy to
basically any other politician in the
country he's pretty much a saint to
compare him to the sex crimes that we're
hearing from the people who have already
fallen in Congress and in the Senate and
and just then the people who we haven't
heard from yet compared him to Bob
Menendez who's accused of repeatedly
having sex with underage hookers not
seventeen year olds over the age of
consent talking about like very very
young girls it it's really reached a
fever pitch
and speaking of Menendez Gordon habla
can we get that guy to resign before
January 17th before there's a Democrat
governor of New Jersey or is that just
not going to happen no it's not going to
happen Michael unfortunately Bob
Menendez was not found guilty in court
and the Democrats certainly found
innocent either but by the way that
trial had nothing to do with the sex
stuff that trial was just about
corruption it was a mistrial but federal
and federal prosecutors who said he
might have had sex with those underage
hookers they have not filed charges no
they have not filed treasure but uh it
seems as if the left is going to go off
of accusations against people like Al
Franken because I think that was
politically advantageous
them at the time when Roy Moore was
being inundated with allegations and
they're not going to do the same thing
for bobbin and as I believe even like
wall the trial was taking place people
were being asked dick Durbin was asked
several other senators as would you
pressure Bodmin as resigned they would
not give a clear straight answer I think
the media is just essentially just going
to bury it and they're not going to push
it any further
absolutely all right gentlemen sad it's
sad to end on that low note of not
impeaching Bob Menendez but c'est la vie
what can you do good to see you all
thank you for coming on that is Cabot
Phillips and Paul Cardinal Bois his
eminence I'll talk to you both soon now
it is time for the mailbag the first
question comes from Joseph oh you know
I'm sorry guys I want this is such a
good question
it's about Islam it's about the religion
of peace but if you don't subscribe to
the daily wire.com you can't see it I
want you to see it go to the daily
wire.com we got to say goodbye to
Facebook in YouTube to all of our
current subscribers thank you very much
you keep the lights on you make cocoa
FFA fill up magically in my left
Esther's tumblr for those who haven't
subscribed daily wire.com right now it
is $10 per month or $100 for an annual
membership what do you get for that
we're all capitalists we don't like
regulation well you get me you get the
end of Clavin show you get the Ben
Shapiro show
yada-yada-yada who cares guys you will
not survive the repeal of net neutrality
without a leftist here's tumblr you
won't do it you're you are guaranteed to
drown so run don't walk scurry you know
I guess it's on your keyboard so you
won't run scurry to the Daily wire right
now daily wired.com you have to get this
leftist ears tumblr please it's for your
own health daily wire calm we'll be
right back
[Music]
okay there's questions from Joseph hi
potentate Knowles if Islam is the
religion of peace then why do so many of
the flags that represent Islamic
countries have swords crossing over the
nation of Israel Joe I'm not sure about
the Israel part of that but they yeah
there aren't swords on these Muslim
flags I've traveled a bit around the
Middle East and the UAE and Oman and
Lebanon and yeah you see the symbolism
of the sword pretty frequently the
reason for that is that Islam spread by
the sword I don't know the symbolic
significance of it and why they chose it
for their flag but the reason that it
rings true for us and and makes us
wonder about the connection is that
Islam spread by the sword so Islam began
a lot of people don't know this Islam
began when Muhammad the supposed prophet
of these Islamic religion when Muhammad
accompanied his uncle Abu Talib on a
trip to Syria and while in Syria they
came across a heretical Christian monk
his name was bashira or Sergius in the
latinized version but is known as
bashira
and he was a heretical monk they don't
know which version of heresy but it's
supposed to be either arianism or
nestorianism or Gnosticism Nazarene ISM
all various heresies that deny the
divinity of Christ it was immediately
after this trip that Muhammad began to
form the Islamic religion and to write
the Quran and go on conquering much of
his area
oh we know when it comes to the sword
that when Muhammad arrived at Medina he
slaughtered a Jewish tribe here the Banu
Qurayza slaughtered all of them beheaded
all of the men in that group it's very
hard to describe that as a religion of
peace but really that is just a
euphemism and a platitude that is used
by people who don't want to grapple with
religion itself and the good that Islam
contains within it and also all of these
bad things that clearly clearly have led
to a horrible atrocities all around the
world and certainly within our century
they want to
their head in the sand to use an image
and they don't want to acknowledge that
but you can't solve a problem if you're
not willing to engage honestly with it
and engaging honestly with what Islam
offers which is theologically true and
good and what it carries with it what
cultural baggage it carries with it and
historical baggage that isn't very much
not good for civilization is that it
that's the first step to solving the
problem
next question from Seth dear Michael
what is your best reason for being
Catholic as opposed to Protestant and
what is it that you think that
Protestantism is lacking its lacking the
Pope of course also do you believe in
the idea of a rapture thank you for a
great show I love listening haven't
missed an episode yet thank you very
much Seth appreciate that the reason I'm
a Catholic I I was I suppose I was
baptized as a Catholic when I was a baby
and by the time I was confirmed I was an
atheist or a strongly agnostic that's
why I chose Thomas as my confirmation
name I was an atheist for about a decade
and be slowly
various philosophers and writers and
conversations I had began to chip away
at my atheism and then I reverted to
Christianity some some evangelical
writers brought me back to Christianity
certain Calvinists and then ultimately
I've arrived full circle back at the
Catholic Church the reason for that
there are a few reasons for that I'll
give you just a handful the seems to me
very convincing that the Incarnate son
of God the divine logos of the universe
the total metaphysical becoming physical
entering into his creation in a
particular place in a particular time in
a particular body through a particular
woman with particular apostles dying on
a particular cross executed condemned to
death by a particular man he would have
a particulars
it would have a church that is real and
tangible it would have a clergy when he
says to Peter Peter your Simon I now
call you Peter and on this rock which is
a pun I will build my church and here
are the keys to the kingdom of heaven
and whatever you bind on earth will be
bound in heaven whatever you loose on
earth will be loosed in
he's giving that to a man that that
isn't meaningless that we can't if you
realize that or try to universalize that
he's talking to a person and so there's
that aspect that the reality of the
sacraments the reality of the physical
and the metaphysical coming into union
heaven and earth coming into Union in
the bread which is the the sacrifice
Paul writes about that wonderfully and
Christ talks about it very seriously and
he says I know this is a hard saying I
know you don't believe me but you have
to because it's true so there's that
aspect it also was basically the
unquestioned position of civilization
until the sixteenth century so there
were always little heretical movements
Santa Claus Saint Nicholas famously
punched The Heretic
arias in the face of the Council of
Nicaea but even after the Great Schism
there was still a recognition of one
universal church with a clergy with the
theology and that had a had a leader and
there was some question over how much
power that leader should exert
temporally there's that aspect as well
the there is much to offer in
Protestantism there Protestants or you
know CS Lewis is one of the greatest
apologists of the century and he's
ostensibly a Protestant the issue of
various Protestant denominations one you
see that they keep multiplying there's
so many a church will always break into
if it isn't grounded in that on that
solid foundation on that rock but the G
K Chesterton writes about this in
orthodoxy
he said the trouble with heresy is not
that it's the promotion of Vice it's not
just saying yeah we in our version of
the church we're gonna go cheat on our
wives yeah that's gonna be a lot of fun
will show you pope it isn't that it's
that it's the promotion of one virtue at
the expense of others so one might one
one church might focus only on mercy or
on compassion and to the exclusion of
justice or to the exclusion of prudence
might say well you know we we don't
think that we should punish any crimes
whatsoever and another church might say
we are gonna punish crimes as hard as
possible we're gonna deter everybody
those are two extremes in
in a theologically illuminating extremes
there is grace and there's liberty so
some churches might say you have
absolutely no freewill whatsoever you
are just a mindless robot being sucked
up in various waves and only grace
matters whatsoever to your life or to
your salvation and then moralizing
churches might say yeah grace that
doesn't play a big part it's just your
liberty is your choice it's your ability
to do things and earn your way into
heaven but that isn't true and then
there's the Catholic answer which
balances these extremes and it says God
comes down the mountain but you have the
free will to turn to him and we see this
in Mary in in the Annunciation of Christ
to Mary the angel Gabriel comes down and
says Mary you hail Mary full of grace
you're blessed among women you are going
to conceive a baby of the Holy Spirit
and then heaven holds its breath the
heavens and the earth hold their breath
and Mary says I am the servant of the
Lord
I am your obedient servant thy will be
done and she says yes she obeys and she
accepts that and that unity of grace and
free will is glorious and it results in
the the Incarnation it results in the
divine logos becoming a man so that a
one thing that recommends the Catholic
Church I think is balancing itself
between these extremes and these
ideologies it's no coincidence that the
Protestant revolution in part caused
modernity in part was caused by
modernity and it Frank breaks off into
various ideologies but when it comes to
religion I would I would resist ideology
and I would I would look for the the
sturdy bark of Peter that doesn't tip
all the way to one side or the other but
remains stabilized okay next question
from James dear Michael Knowles king of
trolls in your infallible except when
fallible opinion how should proponents
of traditional family structure view
homosexual couples adopting children
being raised by biological parents isn't
the best interests of the child but
there are situations where it isn't and
adoption is the best option if the
parents can't care for the child if
they're dirty rotten bums or addicts
absolutely Ken's same-sex couples create
a loving and healthy climate for the
child as effectively as ahead
sexuals if yes should same-sex couples
be permitted to adopt children where we
should we draw the moral and legal line
PS would you ever consider growing a
mustache okay good question obviously
they can provide a good home for a child
that's certainly the case the the legal
issue when it comes to this is does can
single parents adopt children
if single parents can adopt children if
a single woman can adopt a child then of
course a homosexual couple should be
able to adopt a child and it's been for
decades now that single parents can
adopt children so given that premise
homosexual couples should be able to can
they give a good home of course there is
a question of what what a marriage is
and what a family is so there there is a
modern view that the sexes are identical
that men and women are exactly the same
they're not different and therefore by
that logic of course homosexuals could
raise children just as well as anybody
there's also the complementarity of the
sexes which is that men and women are
different they complement one another
they're not the same thing and this
seems to be the ideal unit for children
to be born and raised this is probably
why until modernity until very very
recently that was the only way that
children could be conceived and
basically the way that they were raised
we we have shifted culturally I mean
there and legally so certainly it will
be the case in the future that
homosexual couples can adopt children
but these questions of gender are men
and women the same are they different
that's totally going to inform it until
we say that men and women are
complementary that children are not
something to have to make us feel good
but or we have to struggle to have you
know to have children we have children
and we serve them and it's about the
child not about the parents we're going
to see the same the same culture that
we've been seeing now and it would be
disingenuous to say well single parents
can adopt kids but not gay couples that
that would be discrimination and given
those premises it doesn't work next
question Mike Miley I often get into
discussions regarding the great economy
Trump inherited from Obama and have
nothing in our press
to economic state our because of
anything Trump has done in fact they add
that he's done nothing can you give me
some talking points as a response to
these claims I would be glad to do that
second quarter economic growth was 3.1
percent third quarter economic growth
was three point three percent over the
expectation which was three point two
Barack Obama is the first president
since Herbert Herbert Hoover not to
achieve three percent economic growth in
any year of his presidency closest he
came was 2.6 percent in 2015
unemployment is at four point one
percent a 16 year low under Barack Obama
zero percent interest rates got
unemployment down to four point nine
percent but underemployment was rampant
the gig economy was everywhere a lot of
that is part-time work consumer
confidence is at the highest level since
2000 NFIB shows that small business
optimism is way up since the election
these are changes since the election
sure the stock market has grown steadily
for a decade or for nine years or
whatever that is but all of those other
numbers we can attribute to Donald Trump
and we can't attribute to Barack Obama
that is a sign of the Trump economy
obviously there are the economy is
complicated you can't say that on the
late January when Donald Trump is
inaugurated then it all becomes
President Trump but he has done
marvelously well and no no economists
would question that from Casey dear
Michael King trolls Knowles my Lutheran
mother will be accompanying my Catholic
aunt on a trip to the Vatican for Easter
Sunday Mass that's very nice even though
my mom is not Catholic she understands
the magnitude of the trip she would like
to take this opportunity to do something
special for other family members who are
Catholic but she doesn't know what to do
do you know any suggestions that would
make for a meaningful gift yes one thing
you could do which is entirely free and
I know that that is a price that we all
can afford is to get tickets for a papal
audience so I did this I just kind of
stumbled into it when I was there I was
still basically an atheist I think at
the time I got into st. Peter's and we
were there a lot of people there in the
square but you're right up there and I
saw Pope Benedict give a blessing and
speak in a gazillion languages and pray
and it was really beautiful and really
in retrospect
sticks with you it's a very significant
event so you can do that I would be wary
of any of the rosary beads blessed by
the Pope that they sell around the
Vatican I'm very skeptical that the Pope
has blessed all of those gazillion
rosary beads that they sell there so in
terms of physical things I wouldn't
quite do that if you're in the
neighborhood I would go check out
Caravaggio as a calling of Saint Matthew
which is san luigi de french az it's
right near the pantheon in the piazza
navona that is it's a really wonderful
painting there's so much to do around
there and if you're totally out of
options take her out to a nice lunch the
Italians do lunch very well it takes a
very long time and you'll be very full
afterward next question
from Zachary professor Knowles my 16
year old little sister is starting to be
influenced by her lefty friends in high
school and is questioning why she should
be a Republican Republicans are of
course mean and illogical luckily she's
open-minded and wants to chat with me
about my conservative values how should
I begin my explanation of conservatism
to my little sister help it's not too
late your little sister is in high
school she's being influenced by her
lefty friends
that's good that's the time for that the
time to believe lefty thoughts is when
you're a teenager and you don't know
anything and then when you know things
then you'll move further to the right I
even went through a little bit of this
phase when I was in high school because
these left-wing thoughts are appropriate
to children who are both arrogant and
uneducated and then hopefully you can
work on both of those things over time
and you will move further to the right
I'm sure I wouldn't shove it down her
throat though I would I would rather I
would take almost like a meta political
approach to this and ask her why she's
so confident that these dummies are
right and why these things that she's
learning or right
probably the curriculum that she's
studying from is teaching her a lot of
nonsense and the people don't know very
much and it's an age where you're just
insufferable so I wouldn't give her too
much grief for that I would I would
point out that all of those people and
all of these assumptions
she's taking for granted or they're on
shaky ground
the poem that comes to mind is a little
learning is a dangerous thing
drink deep or taste not the pure in
spring their shallow drafts intoxicate
the brain and drinking largely Sobers us
again so bill Whittle talks about this
he says there's island 129 island 120 of
this around IQ of 120 you know and it's
people it's like the New York Times
editorial board the New York Times op-ed
columnist they all have a kind of
middling intelligence and they are
extremely left-wing and people of kind
of middle intelligence they they're like
yeah man they're totally right oh man
David Brooks oh yeah the Paul Krugman
they're really speaking to me and people
who have lower intelligence or higher
intelligence are both conservative so
they're Morgan sir ative it's a sandwich
but it's just people in the middle who
don't realize how stupid they are but
they're smarter than your average Joe
they're the ones who are convinced of
lefty stuff I would I would go to that I
you know and then you can tell her to
read
I don't know Edwin Burke or Bill Buckley
or whatever but in the meantime I would
have her look around and say are these
people really so smart are these ideas
that you're being told really so
convincing or is it just fashionable and
teenagers are contrarian and that might
get to her from Samuel dear Michael
recently Pope Francis stated the English
translation of the our Father ought to
be changed from and lead us not into
temptation - and may we not be led into
temptation her a few other versions of
that he was speaking an Italian when he
made these remarks I think he says that
this is a more accurate translation from
the Vulgate version at nanos inducas in
tentationem does not seem to support his
story can you enlighten us on the Greek
front and what are your thoughts on his
decision and opinion on the matter sure
I wrote a piece on this and I don't have
ancient Greek and my Latin is very poor
but fortunately the heir to the throne
of the multiverse Spencer Clavin is an
ancient Greek scholar at Oxford so I
talked to him about this Pope Francis's
translation while creative doesn't
appear to be precise because in and and
this is a reminder too that the Pope is
only infallible when he speaking
availably and that's not very frequently
and not in this case the the Greek a a
seems to be in two just like in the
Latin in inducas in tentationem is in
two so it's someone is leading us into
temptation in this line and who is doing
the tempting or who is doing the trial
or who's doing the experiment is unclear
I could someone could lead me to to a
boxing ring and then some other guy
could beat me up but the question is who
is doing the leading and then who is
doing the tempting it's unclear who's
doing the tempting which is Pope
Francis's point he says God doesn't
tempt us that's his view of things but
the leading is pretty clear because we
know from two paragraphs earlier in
Matthew that prayer comes from Matthew
and two paragraphs earlier Christ is led
by the spirit into the wilderness to be
tempted by the devil and then two
paragraphs later we get lead us not into
temptation so it seems to me who is
doing the leading is very clear and that
is God and this more creative abstract
looser translation that the Pope has
suggested is is just not as precise and
it's not as theological a difficult to
grapple with nevertheless God is doing
the leading from the scripture in the
Greek in the Latin in the English in the
Italian and the the question of why he
does that why he leads us to be tested
to the trial even to be tempted by the
devil in the book of Job God allows the
devil to tempt Joab all he likes why he
does that as a theological question and
I think that that problem helps us to
understand the world a little bit better
in our relationship to him but I would
stick with the old translation I think
it's good enough for me that old-time
religion ok one last question from
Garret it is often said that you need to
understand the other person's argument
better than they do to beat them how far
should I take this should I read marks
and books written by atheists or should
I deepen my understanding of capitalism
in Christianity instead in short I'm
worried that if I take the understanding
the other person's side point of view
too literally I could have used that
time to better my understanding of my
own ideology let's begin at the blast
part
don't have an ideology don't try to
resist ideology obviously our political
thinking becomes ideological to varying
degrees
don't set out for one the reason you
believe certain things the reason you
might line up with some ideologies is
because you see the world in a certain
way and they describe it but ideology as
Michael Oakshott said is the formalized
abridgement of the supposed substratum
of rational truth contained in the
tradition that is a lot of degrees away
from the tradition and the world that we
see before us and reality and truth I
would go for that first I wouldn't worry
too much about saying I think I'm a
conservative or I think I'm a
libertarian and so I'm only gonna read
these right-wing books or conversely I'm
gonna read Marx and Engels exclusively
so I can prove them wrong
I wouldn't even read those books that
way I would read them openly I wouldn't
read them in the the school of
resentment where you hate the writers
and you prejudge the texts read the
texts let them speak to you you'll
understand why Marx is wrong here's that
line that lefties read Marx and
conservatives understand Marx that's
certainly true I might go back a little
further before marks before modernity
and read where those works come from I
would read classics I would read the
classic Greek philosophers and writers I
would read all the way up through the
Roman Empire through the Middle Ages
right then you then you're bumping up
against modernity and then you can start
engaging with those but certainly read
everything if the reason that you should
believe certain political points of view
and religious points of view is because
you think they're true and if you think
they're true then you don't need to
worry about reading an atheist or
reading Marx because they might shake
your worldview or the way you see things
the truth is it comes above all things
CS Lewis said some version of a madman
can no easier write out the block out
the Sun by writing darkness on his cell
walls his insane asylum walls then we
can block out the truth by repeating
falsehood you can't block it out the
truth will shine through the truth above
all things so read those I'd read it
with an open mind that's what separates
us from those ideologues
then and then you'll come to hopefully
correct conclusions and you won't be all
angry and ideological like those lefties
okay that's our show we got a run out of
here filming a special project that I
can't tell you about so go over the
claim on this weekend that will save you
there the claim last weekend that will
destroy you and the project that will
save you another Kingdom is available I
think tomorrow or it's dropping early in
the morning so make sure you download
that it really helps us out if you leave
five star reviews downloaded we're still
pitching this thing around Hollywood
they're still listening to us we've got
a ton of great reviews and listenership
if you can keep pumping that around send
it to your families at Christmas that
will really help us out we appreciate it
until Monday I am Michael Knowles this
is the Michael Noel's show I will see
you then
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Marshall Benson executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey supervising producer
Mathis Glover our technical producer is
austin stevens edited by Alex's and Garo
audio is mixed by Mike Cora Mina hair
and makeup is by Jeshua alvera the
Michael Knoll show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2017